good morning
it being 10 o'clock I'll call the fiscal
committee to order on for Thursday
September 14 2023.
first item on the agenda is the
acceptance of the minutes of the
previous meeting from August 11th so
move second
Senator gray moves Senator Bradley
seconds that we adopt the minutes as
written
you see are you ready for the question
all in favor say aye aye opposed no
those are adopted so is that all the
minutes
August 11th how about June 23rd and May
19th
my signature
yep even though I wasn't here
but okay
okay
moving on to tab three
from the legislative performance audit
and oversight committee we have a
request to do a performance audit of the
Department of state's division of
archives and Records management
presented by Senator Rosenwald
is there is there a second to adopt that
recommendation
second by Senator Gray
further discussion seeing none
do you find it
way to the clerk gets gets to the right
page
yes got him all right so it was
Rosenwald and gray
all right
are you ready for the question all in
favor say aye aye aye opposed no
the request is adopted
excuse me
tabs four through eight are a consent
calendar
I have already had requests to remove
under tab six items 23 267 under Tab 7
23 268 and that into Tab 8 23251
is there any other items to be removed
from the consent calendar
under tab seven was two two six eight
two three two six eight
move to accept the consent calendar as
amended
motion by Senator Gray
second by Senator Rosenwald to accept it
with those exceptions
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor of adopting
the consent calendar as proposed say aye
aye opposed no
the rest of the consent calendar is
adopted we will now move on on Tab six
so item 23 267.
thank you
and this is the Department of Health and
Human Services
you see Mr White is here to answer
questions
representative erf is recognized for a
question
it was about the disproportionate share
of hospitals
good morning thanks for being here
um sorry I have
a couple questions
first down on
page
three
towards the bottom
there are two statements uh the last
sentence of number of statement number
of number one is the UCC which refers to
the um uncompensated care cost is then
split evenly between state and federal
funds and then the next paragraph States
the source of funds is 100 federal funds
so what's being split
sure
um good morning members of the committee
my name is Nathan white I'm the Chief
Financial Officer of the Department of
Health and Human Services
this item here we are there's a couple
of things going on as you'll see in the
series of tables number one is we're
accepting additional federal funds
number two into the division of Medicaid
services budget then you're seeing those
funds transfer into New Hampshire
Hospital's budget
um the funds that we're accepting uh
these these represent the um the the
uncompensated care costs and so when
um New Hampshire hospital to come up
with the figures they're looking at what
were our expenses what were the revenues
that we received and and there's there's
a little bit more methodology to this
but then what is the difference and that
total difference from that 50 is state
if it was Medicaid and 50 or sorry
Federal and 50 was State and so the
funds that we're receiving here these
represent the uncompensated costs of the
state and so there's there's two um
allotments that we're pulling from one
is from our 2000 19
audited dish figures which is about 3.4
or I don't know about 3.4 million off
top of my head and then the remaining
amount is from 2021 the estimated
amounts that we have we still have
several hundred thousand dollars in the
future that we may come back to fiscal
for once we uh go through the audit
process but that is what that represents
uh representative Erv
so when it says the source of funds 100
Federal how does that jive with what you
just said the source of funds that we
are accepting is a hundred percent
federal funds that we are receiving from
the federal government as part of this
program
the original expenses that the state
incurred that were uncompensated were
were 50 state 50 Federal but what we're
getting back is a hundred percent
federal funds to cover the 50 of the
state side
okay so the federal funds are covering
the state portion yes of uncompensated
costs okay
so the bigger question I have is this
makes reference to a fiscal note from
2022.
and basically says everything in that
and pretty much everything I may not I
mean be a little bit inaccurate there
but many of the things that were in that
note are now being funded in this note
I'm just wondering what happened to the
5.6 million dollars that was funded in
that note from 2022.
good morning Ellen Lapointe the CEO at
New Hampshire Hospital thank you for the
question so in terms of the projects
that are being funded there were some of
these projects that had to be unfunded
and have the funding rerouted to make
the enf construction project as well as
the forensic Hospital construction
project hole so that speaks to the vast
majority of why
you're seeing some redundancy in some of
these projects with our request
thank you for that was there a separate
thing that came through fiscal that
related to returns for those funds yes
there was a separate item we brought
forward two items La it might have been
last October to fiscal for approval to
cover some of the increased costs
related to to construction where we
repurposed a portion of these funds I
don't remember off the top of my head
000 is coming to mind for some reason I
can certainly provide that to the
committee if that would be helpful yeah
it'd be great to send me then of course
then fiscal notes that reference what
happened there thank you
Senator D'Alessandro moves to accept
item 267 and I believe it was Senator
bird cell seconds
further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say aye aye oppose no that
item is adopted next item that is
removed from consent is under tab seven
and it's number two six eight
and again it's a recognize
representative erf for a question
so my question here is down at the
bottom of page three
it talks about the the bottom line
purpose of this
initial Grant here is to be eligible to
eligible to apply for a four-year Grant
to actually do the work and my question
about that is is it known at this point
that that
we know non-federal funds used in the
implementation of whatever that Grant is
if it's approved
so good morning for the record I'm Katya
Fox I'm the director of the division for
Behavioral Health and New Hampshire is
eligible to apply for um the four-year
multi-million dollar Grant at the end of
the planning process there were 15
grants that were awarded
across the country similar to this one
and 10 of those States will be eligible
for that multi-million dollar Grant in
the future
it will be a hundred percent federal
funds
thank you
further questions on item 268 Senator
gray not really a question but we
noticed that in this item the word
retroactive is in there certainly we are
interested in making sure that all of
these and we even started the process
early this year to make sure that we
didn't have these so again comment and
hopefully there won't be any more
I'll entertain a motion to adopt FIS
23268.
for a second all right representative
Senator Rosenwald moves Senator Dallas
Andrews seconds to adopt item 23 268 is
there any further discussion seeing none
of you ready for the question all in
favor say aye
opposed no that item is adopted excuse
me
last item removed from consent is under
tab seven
23 251 yeah under tab eight excuse me
last item on Tab a
h
looking now at FIS 23 251
.
I believe a senator had a question on
this
representative Senator Dallas uh
directed nice to see you this morning
what's what is the story of the fish
hatcheries now we had X number that we
were going to look at we were going to
cut that down to it to a manageable
number and refurbish those situations it
it currently there's a discharge from
the Fisheries that's contaminating uh
either the soil or the water what's the
story there how are we dealing with that
uh good morning my name is for the
record my name is Scott Mason executive
director of New Hampshire Fish and Game
um Senator we are still actively in
litigation you reference
um the discharge at the Powder Mill
Hatchery over New Durham
um and we are still in active litigation
on that
um the judge has held his decision
pending final negotiation between EPA
and clf and New Hampshire Fish and Game
on how we're going to come into
compliance with our new neptis permit
for the discharge over there
um
so I still
you know at this point we're still we're
still in active litigation so it
unfortunately limits exactly what we can
talk about until we finish that
litigation I will say that we are
uh actively working with EPA and clf I'm
actually meeting with them tomorrow on
this issue
um and we are anticipating an agreement
by the end of the year on how we will
come into compliance with our new permit
at New Durham
um
we're currently working with our with
the New Hampshire Public Works
Department on an RFQ for a design
project on on rebuilding Hatchery
and we received two permits on the RF
I'm sorry two proposals on the RFQ and
we are actively negotiating with our
first choice and I believe I I would
dare say we're making good progress and
we anticipate being before the uh
governor and Council in December with a
proposed contract for design on Hatchery
you know rebuilding hatcheries then
um
we are currently actively working on
trying to reduce any discharges that we
have our two hatcheries that obviously
the new Durham Hatchery
um we have a problem there and the other
Hatchery where we have a problem as far
as the discharge goes is up in Berlin
and we're actively working at both
hatcheries to try to reduce the
discharges coming out of those
hatcheries the
the new Durham one we we're still not
quite meeting the 12 parts per billion
discharge permit that the net that the
neptis permit has even with all of the
changes that we've made there
um changing our best management
practices there changing the type of
feed we're feeding the fish
um in Berlin we are actively looking we
have changed where we're keeping the
fish and we are no longer actively
discharging a New York Pond which is a
water body that has uh phosphorus
contamination issue
further questions too further question
so what would all of this is is taken
care of
how many fish hatcheries will will still
be active
I don't have an exact figure at this
time
um
the the goal that we're going to have is
to maintain current Fish Production so
regardless of whether I have three
hatcheries or five hatcheries or six
hatcheries the goal the governor has
given to us is to maintain current total
Fish Production
the the three you know one of the
reasons why we like to have hatcheries
it's just easier for transportation and
stocking if you know if I had one big
hatchery in the central part of the
state it would
um we would have to change you know our
Fleet of trucks and we'd have to change
the way we do some of our stocking
um so for us
um it's a little easier for us to have
you know multiple hatcheries spread out
through the state
thank you thank you Mr
the questions on the item
seeing none it'll entertain a motion to
adopt
okay motion by Senator Bradley second by
Senator bird cell to adopt FIS 23 251
further discussion seeing Nani ready for
the question all in favor say aye
I suppose no the item is adopted moving
on to the regular calendar under tab
nine first item is
23 258.
Department of administrative services
are there any questions on the item
seeing none how you write adoption okay
thank you
Senator gray moves to adopt 23 258
Senator Bradley seconds
further discussion seeing nunny ready
for the question all in favor say aye
aye opposed no
the item is adopted moving on to item
under tab 10.
23-2-5-9
Department of administrative Services
again
thank you
Senator dallasandro moves 23-259 so in
the bird sells seconds are there any
further discussion seeing Nani ready for
the question all in favor of adoption
say aye aye opposed no the item is
adopted
next item
is under table uh
the tab 11.
the read
regenerative Workforce Development
program
are there any questions on this item
sing none move adoption
okay Senator gray moves adoption
seconded by
um
second
uh representative Mooney
further discussion
let's see it I'm trying to remember now
whether you're an alternate today
no you are a full member
you're okay I should have accepted your
second anyway you have a motion in a
second further discussion seeing none
are you ready for the question all in
favor of adopting 23 270 say aye aye
opposed no
the item is adopted
moving on to 12 10 excuse me tab 12
.
is 23278
natural and cultural resources
this is the routine
increase in the skiing
uh Levy
any discussions uh Senator Rosenwald for
a question
good morning Sarah Stewart commissioner
of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources and I'm here with
Greg Keeler who has worked at Canon for
a number of years and is stepping up to
help an interim position while we look
for our new Mountain manager
thank you good morning commissioner
um I'm happy to see that the price
increases are really
much smaller this year than last but I
just since you don't have it on the
spreadsheet what is the processing fee
for the free
season pass for
New Hampshire residents over 65. thank
you
um so I'm going to take a crack at it
and then I'll let Greg correct me
um so there is no processing fee if you
show up the day of and go to the window
to get your free pass but there is a
processing fee if you choose to get a
seasons pass and that is 44 thank you
you're welcome
remove the item second Senator rosenwal
moves to adopt 23 278 send the
dalessandro seconds is there any further
questions or further discussions from
the committee seeing Nani ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no the item is adopted
moving on to tab 13.
foreign
okay I think I heard it was uh Senator
bird cell moves to approve Senator
Dalessandro's seconds to adopt item
23-271. is there any further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say aye aye opposed no
the item is adopted
moving on to tab 14.
number 23 272
from The Office of Consumer advocate
move the item Senator D'Alessandro moves
to adopt second was I believe Senator
Bradley
23-272 any further discussion seeing
none are you ready for the question all
in favor say aye aye opposed no we have
adopted 23 272 I now recognize the
legislative budget assistance for a
request
good morning for the record crochet
Deputy legislative budget assistant I
come before you today to request the
fiscal committee approve our hiring two
Auditors within our audit division
move to proof second
Senator gray moves to approve the
request Senator Bradley seconds any
further discussion
seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no
permission is granted thank you
information materials any
the members wish to have anybody Senator
Alessandro I thank you Mr chairman uh
item item 15 misleadius the New
Hampshire Youth Development Center
claims Administration that settled but I
was under the impression that
they were going to come today and give
us an update on where things stood with
regard to what happened with the
settlement with the settlement how many
cases have been adjudicated
how many cases have been settled by by
the administrator the amount of money
that's been expended the amount of money
that's left and what the costs have been
for managing this this uh Administration
up up to this point I have I have seen
duber's articles
that indicate
that people have been contacted and then
the ball has been dropped and things
have fallen apart there was one uh these
three women were were uh I guess
initially contacted interviewed and then
it's what's happened it seems like it
that the case has fallen through the
cracks
uh two things are happening the statute
of limitations is is coming rather
quickly and our decision with regard to
the program at the end of it is coming
rather quickly
now we've been told again this is
anecdotally that's 100 million is not
enough well if it's it's not enough how
much has been spent where has the money
been spent why is it why is it not
enough money at this at this point in
time there's got to be a rationale for
what we're doing uh
and it's it seems to be we we need to be
updated on this we're it's our
responsibility we've we voted to put
this in place and uh we we ought to be
making sure that it works and at this
point in time it it doesn't seem to be
to be working there's there's one case
that was settled and I believe there's a
suit in place against
the the person who settled it because it
was supposedly the case of another
person and so there's a lot of
controversy uh around this situation we
need some clarity on what's going on
this is a major situation facing our
state
very expensive yes
Mr Shea can you fill us in you know
obviously we have no item in the in the
book
so as the members that um received the
email I think from Mike Kane the
attorney general and the administrator
for the uh settlement fund are
discussing um based on the last uh
fiscal committee meeting some ideas for
potential changes
um improvements some which may need a
legislative change and they weren't
ready to come before fiscal today
um we had put that on our agenda we had
left it there because at the time we
weren't sure if we were going to get
something
so I think the intention was um that
they maybe come back next meeting
but they do report on a quarterly basis
to some of the issues that Senator
D'Alessandro is concerned about in terms
of the number of settlements and the
costs that have been
um
to the fun to that day for that quarter
there was a request for a private
meeting I believe but it couldn't be
with the whole committee because that
would be illegal but are there any
people that are particularly interested
in this that would like to hit being on
this meeting
thank you
uh comment on that I I have made the
suggestion that you know they meet with
the Republican caucus and the Democratic
caucus which is allowed under our RCA
91a and
will accomplish what we are intending to
do so that has been the suggestion that
I've put out there
and would accomplish I think what we
needed to happen
thank you I'll see if that's possible
um just we're talking about the caucus
of the members of the committee yep yep
all right I'll see if we can arrange
that
anything further on that item
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman I recall the administrator of
the fund was here recently was that as
recent as last month yes thank you he
gave he had a fairly extensive request
for changes to the
so the rules which we granted and he
also had a fairly lengthy discussion of
the procedure as it's moving forward and
we also had quite a list of of numbers
of people they expected to come forward
and it was fairly extensive
the number of cases that they had
preliminarily discussed as Senator
D'Alessandro has mentioned we knew that
this has been ongoing for quite some
time and
expected to make further progress at
this meeting but so far nothing but we
will have those meetings we'll set them
up and uh
we'll let everybody hopefully will come
to some conclusion so
are there any other items under
information that people would like to
have information on
seeing none I guess we're ready for
review of the
audit
I guess we're finishing up earlier than
the audit division expected we would
yeah I know they're on their way
I was delighted to finally find out that
they're having an audit on this
vendor so we have to do this again yep
does the chair want to take a five
minute recess yeah why don't we do that
five minute recess
good morning we took a five minute
recess so we'll shoot everybody back
buddy thank you
good morning and welcome to the
um
the audit division to present
an audit on the internal control review
of vendor accounts
thank you
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record I'm Christine
Young director of audits for the LBA
replacing Steve Smith who as you know
retired this past summer we're here to
present our assessment of the internal
controls in place over the establishment
and maintenance of the state's vendor
accounts Jim lariviere senior manager
with our office was the in-charge
manager on this audit he'll present the
report and also joining us from the
Department of administrative Services is
Sherry Rockburn and Dana call who will
be available to answer questions and
with that I'll turn it over to Jim for
the presentation thank you thank you
good morning chairman Weiler and members
of the committee again for the record my
name is Jim larivier
we are here to present our report on our
assessment of the internal controls in
place over the state's process of
establishing and maintaining vendor
accounts during the nine months ended
March 31st 2022.
if you turn to the table of contents you
will see the executive summary
background in our
audit objective scope and methodology
are located on pages one through seven
there has been no prior audit of this
specific audit topic
the report contains 14 findings and
recommendations
one finding observation number six has
an asterisk suggesting legislative
action may be required
the Department administrative Services
State Treasury and administrative office
of the courts provided Oddity responses
which follow each finding in this report
the department concurred fully with all
observations except for observation
number seven the department concurred in
part
moving on to the background section on
page three
the department administration of
administrative Services has primary
responsibility for the administration
and management of establishing and
maintaining vendor accounts in the state
of New Hampshire's vendor Master file
vendor accounts are used in New
Hampshire first the state's financial
accounting and Reporting System to pay
the state's bills
for audit purposes vendors are
identified or as all entities or
individuals that will or may receive
payment from the state process through
New Hampshire first
vendors consist of businesses providing
products or services to the state
grantees employees reimbursed for travel
or training Medicaid or Medicare
providers jurors and Witnesses abandon
property claimants taxpayers and
governmental entities
it is essential to effectively maintain
the vendor Master file to help prevent
unauthorized activity reduce the risk of
fraud or errors and promote efficiencies
during the audit period the state used
17 Venda classes to categorize vendors
by type
some vendor classes were restricted to
specific State agencies
the number of vendors status and
description of each vendor class is
found on pages four through six
we conducted our audit in accordance
with generally accepted government
auditing standards and as noted on page
seven the purpose of the audit was to
determine whether the controls in place
for establishing and maintaining State
vendor accounts or properly designed
implemented and operating effectively
as reported in the executive summary on
page one
we found that the state's internal
controls were ineffectually designed
implemented and operated to provide
reasonable Assurance the control
objectives including vendor validation
setup modification and maintenance were
achieved
the observations begin on page nine
observation number one we recommend the
department Implement a plan to develop a
secure self-service Vendor Portal that
allows vet vendors to register create a
vendor account provide documentation
required and update information as
needed
the current manual process for
onboarding and updating Venda data
relies mainly on data entry performed by
state personnel and as inefficient and
prone to errors
New Hampshire will soon be the only New
England state that does not offer a
self-service vendor option
observation number two
on page 10 recommends the department
establish a formal risk assessment
process to identify analyze and respond
to risk including performing an
assessment of risks relative to The
Establishment and maintenance of vendor
accounts
observations number three and number
four beginning on page 11 identifies the
need for formal policies and procedures
in observation number three
policies and procedures would Aid State
Personnel in the identification and
assignment of vendors to the proper
vendor class when new accounts are
created
our testing of vendors who provide
services and commodities to the state
found that 25 vendors out of a sample of
75 vendors were placed into the
incorrect vendor class
which may result in inaccurate reporting
of income to the vendors and the
Internal Revenue Service for tax
purposes
we also identified 147 duplicate active
vendor accounts increasing the risk for
duplicate payments other errors are
possibly fraud
observation number four identifies the
need for policies and procedures over
vendor accounts that should be kept
private or sealed
observation number five on page 13.
recommends the department establish a
review and approval control procedure
for the establishment of new New
Hampshire first vendor accounts and to
make changes to existing
existing in information to help prevent
vendors prevent areas of fraud from
occurring without detection and
correction
we noted errors in Vendor data that
likely would have been detected and
corrected timely had an independent
review and approval process been in
place
observation number six beginning on page
noted that 44 out of 50 vendors who
provide services and commodities to the
state did not provide required form W-9
a request for tax identification numbers
and certification form and five of those
50 vendors did not provide alternate W9
application forms required by
administrative rules
moving on to Observation number seven
as noted in the detail at the bottom of
page 16.
vendor income was not reported
completely and accurately in accordance
with federal law for tax reporting
purposes
we recommend the department established
controls over the form 1099 vendor
income reporting process to ensure
compliance with federal tax requirements
in observation number eight located on
page 17
we recommend the department continue to
provide All State agencies with guidance
and training for establishing a new
vendor including when vendors require a
state contract what documentation should
be obtained and the retention policy for
those documents
we also recommend establishing
monitoring controls to ensure that state
agencies are complying with those
requirements
observations number nine and number 10
recommend the establishment of policies
and procedures observation number nine
calls for the Department to establish
policies and procedures requiring the
timely inactivation of vendor accounts
that will no longer be used and
observation number 10 recommends the
department established policies and
procedures to properly restrict system
user access permissions
or mitigating controls if permissions
cannot be restricted
observation number 11 on page 23
identifies errors in New Hampshire first
vendor data and recommends the
department established criteria to only
update active accounts and do so in a
controlled and timely manner to enhance
data integrity and reliability
observation number 12 on page 24
recommends the department first perform
procedures during and after vendor
establishment to ensure vendors are not
federally debarred
second inactivate the barred vendor
accounts in New Hampshire first and
third keep the department listing on the
department's website current
observation number 13 on page 25
recommends the State Treasury and the
department work together to to determine
if a more efficient and secure vendor
enrollment payment process
can be developed using a self-service
Vendor Portal
our final observation observation number
14 on page 26
recommends the department work with the
statutorily established advisory
committee on state procurement
to address procurement and Associated
vendor issues and annually request a
formal report of all findings and
recommendations for proposed legislation
this concludes my presentation we'd like
to thank the department of
administrative Services State Treasury
and all the other agencies for their
assistance and cooperation throughout
the audit thank you
thank you
questions uh I said a statement from the
Comptroller
good afternoon good morning good
afternoon good morning Dana call State
cop trailer uh I do I want to Echo uh
the thanks to the LBA for helping us
with this effort in terms of pointing
out areas where we can look to guide our
policies in the future
um this took probably good off and on
over a year I think of in in a good way
they really uh dug in to the deepest
areas of of our financial system
um and given that we're looking to go
forward with an upgrade to our financial
system this is a great tool to help us
sort of set those policies now as you
can see some things uh did get
decentralized over the course of the
last several years and we don't have a
real strong control in in Das
specifically so this will give us the
the uh the bandwidth to to work on that
so appreciate it and I am happy to take
any specific questions in from my area
pressure trip committee members Senator
dalessandro oh thank you thank you nice
to see you again good to see you too
days in a row
tell me about the capability of our
system to adjust to these changes
will it require new modules uh well what
exactly is is required I remember the
transition from the old system to this
new system
and that was that was a compass of a
tedious process which we've had bitty
bitty bitty uh me and I wish to to
figure but how about this the reports it
it's interesting but uh it indeed talks
about
I think very significant changes that
have to be made are they costly
and how how is this going to happen I
mean I will say that uh this is vendor
creation so we have very strong payment
controls in terms of payments going out
the door our accounts payable system is
is very solid in that sense
um what we've done over the years is by
policy allowed agencies or even
divisions within Das to have controls of
different stages of vendor creation so
what we're looking to do is sort of have
a new workflow in the system that would
allow such as my division to have sort
of final approval on something from a
tax perspective we're the ones who have
to determine who gets 1099 forms and the
like so sometimes if we are not in from
the beginning of the process we can't
really fix it at the back end but what
we're looking to do is get insert our
controls at the beginning of the process
better so that we don't have as much
correcting to do at the back end I do
think our system even today but even
more so when we upgrade will allow us to
do that
Senator gray uh so I took that as a
partial response to seven on page 16 17.
uh
you know you talk about uh decentralized
and everything again a lot of that
seemed to fit in with your your previous
statement I'm interested in what we're
doing to make sure it doesn't happen
Okay and whether that's a check you know
at some point in the process because
these others are you know injuring data
or something
um
I always get concerned when I see you
know Greece in part okay and I always
try to to ask questions about that
because there ought to be some kind of
actionable item with a date certain that
you're going to have a plan to fix it or
whatever so I'll shut up and let you
talk
in in the internal control world we we
obviously
um we're never going to be 100
um accurate is we want to try to set up
controls to minimize the number of
Errors
um I will say that we've had multiple
audits directly from the IRS and we have
fared pretty well in regards to 1099s
and w9s and those buzzwords that you
hear from the IRS
um which is I guess new for the state in
my time because prior to my time I don't
think we had had any IRS audits so I was
a lucky one but I I think that it's a
continuous Improvement cycle I there is
you know there are steps we can take to
try to catch as many things as we can
before they go out the door and that's
what we're looking to do is sort of
bring some of that centrally so it's not
so decentralized we're a big
organization we pay a lot of bills and a
lot of vendors as you can see 200 000
plus active vendors so there is a lot to
manage but
you know our group which is a relatively
small group and accounting services is
gonna is gonna make every effort to try
to stay on top of that did anything
Sherry Rockburn I'm the assistant
commissioner of the department the only
thing I want to Echo in terms of Dana
and I think it responds to both Senator
D'Alessandro and Senator gray is that uh
last year your committee had approved
um money for us to do the infor upgrade
of our financial system in terms of what
we get with that one of the things
that's part of that package is as Jim
had mentioned a supplier Vendor Portal
for them to do some some self-management
and and gather information be more
efficient so a lot of the the
features that we're getting with the
product that we've already are procuring
has a lot of these things in it so as
Dana said this is sort of a really
perfect timing in terms of getting this
so as we're working with our implementer
with our new system our upgrade we can
start to implement some of these changes
with that that's about a two-year year
and a half two-year implementation for
the full upgrade there'll be pieces that
may come on board sooner than that but
that just gives you a little sense of
you know what are we doing going forward
in terms of systems a lot of the things
that are in this report are going to be
addressed with our with the upgrades
that automatically come with that that
product
I have a question for Mr La Revere
um observation number six you have an
asterisk thing legislative correction
but the write-up seems to indicate a
rule change
right we identified that one with an
Asterix because we considered the The
Joint legislative rules committee to be
part of legislation
so well then on the the last comment the
Department administrative Services
response
they say that they have changed it
and and uh
and have
changed that rule
did that
straighten out what does that help with
that observation does it
does it correct it or do we still need
to try to do some legislation
ah
oh yeah I
certainly at this but I'm not 100 yeah
we think it does correct it we yes we
think it does correct it I only have one
more day to file I want to make sure
right I mean I get it right yes we
believe it does but uh I to be 100
certain I would want to go back and look
at it to confirm and say
okay but basically it was the rule that
you want to change rather than law
correct correct it was the rule it was
the rule that was that we had seen the
non-compliance with okay right Senator
Rosenwald for a question
same thing okay
um
further questions from the committee
I'm glad you found an area that had been
overlooked for so long would work thank
you because obviously when we find more
inactive vendor accounts than we find
active ones sometimes a Nova looked for
a very long time
so good work thank you
representative erf
emotion right move to accept place on
file and release to the public in the
usual manner the
second audit
further discussion
seeing any ready for the question all
those in favor say aye aye
oppose note
the motion is adopted thank you for your
good work and I guess administrative
Services got some catching up to do but
I guess they're on the way
this is always helpful that we find out
things that we have overlooked for far
too long
so
good work and we look forward to it
being fixed
now we work on the date of the next
meeting
I have requested that we go to a
Thursday again because of I have a
conflict on the on the Friday
uh 20th would have been the third Friday
is there any problem with going to
Thursday for for the
LBA
we have no issue on that date
I have
I guess in the morning a gel car but we
start at 10 so and then I'm an alternate
on gel car so as long as we do it in the
morning
I can do that because Thursday afternoon
the retirement system meeting is
scheduled for one you're busy
so it didn't have to be the morning
meeting so we could do uh 10 o'clock on
Thursday the 14th 19th
wait a minute I'm in the wrong month
here
let me get to the right month
thank you if I think you're shooting
four 19.
19th
October 19th
is acceptable
all right fiscal at 10
on October 19th
thank you all very much is there
anything else to come before us
motion to adjourn is there a second yes
all in favor say aye aye opposed no we
are adjourned
it was pretty quick thank you very much
awesome well done